comment allez vous je commence avec des
trucs chiants directement la vidéo mais
c'est dans le thème j'ai le droit
j'espère que tout le monde va très bien
en ces temps sergent effectivement ma
coupe de cheveux progresse elle évolue
elle est en train de devenir une frange
aujourd'hui nouveau sombré dit et celui
là il est vous allez avoir envie de ça
ce bris dit
agaçant il va un peu vous énerver et
d'ailleurs c'est le titre du seul bris
dit melli il fouille
je suis parti en espagnol je n'arrive
pas à le dire le non en fait je connais
pas ce mot 1000 lits il fourie a thing
chez pas le dire j'ai atteint ma limite
ce sobre et dit a été créé pour un peu
vous énervez pas trop mais juste un peu
après y'en a qui gère très bien cette
sensation d'un qui arrive à en rire qui
arriva qui fait moi je râle à mort
arrière m'énerve je suis premier degré
en ce moment vous m'entendez et alors le
mec a créé sabre est dit a bien fait son
taf puisque même le design du sobre est
dit est chiant c'est chiant et je peux
pas voir le titre du post j'ai obligé de
faire ça à chaque fois c'est chiant il
ya des gens ils sont faits pour casser
les couilles c'est de dollars avec son
parfait avec le premier poste la
quantité de packaging gâchée pour
acheter tous les équipements
additionnels pour utiliser mon iphone
donc écouteurs charger tout ça tout ça a
été vendu dans une seule boîte ya cinq
ans mais apple a décidé d'arrêter
d'inclure ces trucs dans l'iphone de
base soit c'est l'os bref maintenant
tout est vendu ont séparé donc ça fait
beaucoup plus de déchets pourquoi
pourquoi j'ai besoin de créer un compte
juste pour regarder plus de terreau est
il en fait des caisses mais je comprends
totalement je me suis dit ça chaque
[ __ ] de fois que j'allais sur ping
terrestre et j'ai toujours pas créé de
compte je suis un rageux ils ne
gagneront pas j'utilise le compte de
lucioles en prison totalement gagné mes
parents une salle de bains avec de la
moquette qui remontent le long de la
baie noire
attendez attendez attendez qu'ils aiment
là y'a pas plus crade que de la moquette
c'est terrible ça absorbe toute la merde
et ce à la cacher j'ai uniquement par
allongé trop du mal avec la moquette
j'ai l'impression que la cij la déconne
et que je fais ça il ya de luri qui
compte c'est horrible mais ça me donne
des frissons pour je suis vraiment pas à
l'aise et le saviez vous sa source et
des normes légende je vais donner mais
une mégafête news j'ai appris que
l'étude est elle s'était faite d'une
main on parle vraiment toilettes premier
degré bienvenu que j'ai appris que les
cuvettes était faite de manière à ce que
ça soit le plus âgé nique possible qu'il
y ait le moins de bactéries etc et par
contre quand tu vas dans des toilettes
publiques et tu fais le tour de la
cuvette avec du pq pour pas que ta peau
entre en contact avec la cuve est
maudite bas apparemment c'est moins
génique que de ne pas mettre du pq est
ce vrai ou est ce que je me suis fait
bates par un mec qui souhaitait que je
chope des maladies je n'ai pas la
réponse les plats sont à l'envers ça par
contre ça va être rapide design ça
m'énerve à aucun moment au contraire je
vais le commander ce plat je peux me
confesser vite fait en 5 secondes y
avait un commentaire sur l'une des
dernières vidéo qui disait ça me stresse
il a pas du tout la même tête squeeze
seize mille lacs les gens plus aimé le
commentaire que la vidéo d'accord bas ça
m'a blessé ça m'a blessé puisque quand
j'ai me plaît sur la vidéo je me suis
pas reconnu
c'est totalement vrai je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé mais dans cette vidéo j'ai
une tête c'est pas moi je sais que
j'avais dû raser ma barbe pour x raisons
mais j'ai un agent qui a autre chose
c'est trop stressant est-ce que j'étais
posséder durant cette vidéo plat un
retour ce bris directement après si tu
es dans le thème c'est un truc qui
m'avait un peu énervé on est dans le
thème au nom c'est génial mais il a reçu
une contravention pour excès de vitesse
sauf que sa caisse était sur un camion
direction la fourrière
ça se voit sur la photo en plus haut la
double peine c'est horrible en parlant
de ça j'ai une anecdote pour chaque
poste c'est incroyable y'a pas longtemps
je me suis fait emmener ma voiture deux
fois à la fois hier en une semaine
vous avez dit j'étais bien gas et
j'étais à deux doigts de faire un post
sur ce seul vrai dit des trucs trop
drôle comme la voiture elle a détecté
une mouche qui a été sur un cadavre qui
elle a été déplacée elle s'est mise à
filmer et du coup j'ai toute la scène
quand j'ai vu les images étaient morts
c'est pas si drôle pourtant mes voisins
ont construit une terrasse vue sur ma
chambre
non mais mon gars c'est incroyable et
dans l ue on est il se passe un truc là
ils prennent des infos là et l'étape
d'apprécier de séquestre je suis désolé
mais aucun plaisir à être sur cette
terrasse qui plus est vous avez vu je
râle je suis très premier degré
attention on dirait bien que j'ai pas
pouvoir écouter mon nouveau vinyle merci
peut-être si tu mets ta machine comme ça
ça passe mon mari ne veut pas que la
vitre soit rayé
du coup il a laissé le plastique
pourquoi c'est laurie ya aucun humain
que je comprends moins bien que celui là
la satisfaction que tu as en plus de
retirer ce petit papier quand tu reçois
alors dit quel intérêt d'acheter un pc
gamer si c'est pour qu'il est c'est
peut-être moi des fois il reste un tout
petit bout de plastique à un endroit et
je bloque dessus je n'ai plus qu'un
objectif c'est de le retirer à tout prix
lui il laisse le papier anti annonça à
ça et gassin dans la fosse changer de
mari madame la raison pour laquelle ce
professeur de maths retire des points
utilisé l'addition répéter pour résoudre
cette fois 3 donc cette fois trop égale
15 5 + 5 + 5
non non non il fallait mettre trois plus
trois plus trois plus trois plus trois
c'est moins 1
allez au revoir on se parlera via
deuxième exo dessiner un tableau pour
montrer et résoudre 4 x 6 ok une ligne
de quatre une colonne de six ça fait 4 x
6 24 excellent non une ligne de 6 et des
colonnes de quatre mois un chao
je me suis toujours demandé si j'étais
prof si je me serais pas à manger des
fois de certaines frustrations de ma vie
en corrigeant quelques copies écoute
bien y en a qui ne se prive pas pas
besoin je devienne professeurs pour que
ça existe l'électricien a installé un
câble à travers un cerceau où on avait
oublié ta fil de cette heure ne pourra
plus passer la journée à faire du oui
j'ai commandé 27 livres sur amazon en
une fois j'ai reçu 27 boîte avec un
livre dans chacune
[Musique]
je suis content que des gens qui aient
la même haine que moi vis-à-vis des
emballages inutiles des fois je commande
un truc qui fait sa taille et dans un
carton comme ça fait un effort les
garages or même avec un ciseau tu as du
mal à l'ouvrir et dans le plastique est
en plastique je râle sèche qu'on sera
les premiers de grippe ne s'abrite pas
matrix est si seulement il y avait un
moyen moins cher plus esthétique et plus
naturel de se protéger de la pluie ça ça
va dans le film les gars mais vous en
avez pas marre
après attention en hiver quand il ya
plus de feuilles bonté pas protéger de
la pluie c'est peut-être pour ça en vrai
ah je prend très à coeur ces postes
attention de la limonade fait maison
bien fraîche
non ça c'est trop ceci dit j'ai reçu
plus temps passe et moins ça mon comm ca
ouvertement à un moment donné les
humains sont dits frérot c'est un peu
trop venez au calme un peu le mensonge
ou alors je me nourris depuis la manière
dont ma copine à ranger les courses avec
les sacs ya zéro et fort c'est
hallucinant mec ça me rassure de voir ça
j'suis pas le pire en fait quand ça
arrive 50,1 km heure 50 km heure vous
êtes mauvaise langue ça n'arrive pas si
souvent tout le temps tous les jours mon
frérot quand les poids lourds se
doublent extasions milan là la manoeuvre
les gommes comme celle ci j'ai jamais
compris fléau il ya des gommes c'est
plus une gomme c'est un surligneur ça
s'appelle d'accord elle est belle je
suis d'accord là les mignonnes et tout
on a envie de l'aimer prendre soin
d'elle de lui faire gober des belles
écritures mais c'est un surligneur mon
école a banni le jeu du dinosaure sur
chrome
non guy salut à tous mes frères et
soeurs encore à l'école
[Musique]
what the fuck je suis confus avec le
covan on n'a pas le droit de manger en
intérieur mais on peut manger en
intérieur tant que l'intérieur est à
l'extérieur galette c'est du génie une
techniquement la police elle arrive elle
ne peut rien faire rien dire elle peut
juste s'asseoir et commander une pizza
d'accord à la personne qui est inventé
ces petits trucs qui scelle les sauces
tu n'es pas mon ami je te hais et mecque
et la languette pour rattraper le truc
fait moins d'un millimètre
à chaque fois je m'en sors pas du coup
je ce plan avec un couteau et je fais le
tour c'est terrible quoi premier degré à
fond comme en ont beau père a décidé de
refermer la boîte de céréales après en
avoir mangé hier soir franchement ça me
choque pas tant que ça du coup chez
andrade chrome etc
enfin j'avoue je ferme surtout les
sachets de croquettes ou de chips comme
ça pas les boîtes de céréales mais
pourquoi pas fermer les banques de
céréales comme ça en vrai c'est pas
énervant ça ok c'est juste normal ça y
est j'ai un vieux complexe une option de
zoom qui rend les choses plus petit
ces volontaires l'objet pas ou fait si
tu zoom tu vas le voir dont tu vas pas
l'acheter ses sorts pensant volontaire
le simple fait que ça existe une plaque
par balle à mettre dans les cartables
est-ce que vous résoudre le problème des
armes un peu trop accessible où est-ce
qu'on fait encore plus de thunes grâce à
ce problème
quelqu'un me fut au papier toilette dans
mon épicerie locale
ça existe c'était pour se venger de ceux
qui se ruent sur le pq à chaque
confinement je trouve en bas au nom ça
oh non je suis pire pour ça ma copine a
ouvert des nouvelles bouteilles d'eau
avant d'avoir fini les anciennes aidez
moi s'il vous plaît écoutez il parle de
moi je sors avec ce mec s'il y en a
parmi vous qui étudie la psychologie
peut-être allez-vous mme apporter des
réponses
j'ai du mal à finir les choses quand je
mange un repas je dois laisser un tout
petit bout dans le coin de l'assiette
mais je fais pas exprès ce n'est pas
volontaire juste j'arrive pas à finir
donc j'essaie avec les bouteilles d'eau
geste avec les repas les sectes ou y at
il une explication psychologique est ce
que ça va révéler que j'ai le même cycle
logique un serial killer j'espère pas
[Musique]
quoi je suis désolé mais c'est le
meilleur vol
c'est le moins discret de tous avec une
perche de 14 mètres je vais aller
tâtonner l'arbre du voisin c'est un gros
mais voir marcher [ __ ] tu as reçu une
notification de mon appli irobot le
roomba a besoin de votre aide
il est bloqué à côté d'une falaise la
falaise en question qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont cons ces aspects suis désolé j'en
avais avant et j'ai arrêté parce que
quand je passe la spirale mais trois
minutes quand lui passe la spi ça mais
trois heures et du coup ça fait du bruit
c'est chiant pour les animaux mais qu'à
observer c'est incroyable ils sont
attachés en fait ils ont l'air idiot
s'est buté il se tourne un peu y
corriger rugby turgut tu te retrouves à
avoir de l'empathie pour ton aspirateur
c'est relou ah oui ce truc là
écoutez moi même je ne mets plus aucun
tweet asip uniquement pour cette raison
c'est insupportable ça fait des années
que vous m'avez pas vu avec un sweat
comme ça sur yuko champions n'a jamais
eu et il y en aura jamais c'est pour
cette raison invoquée note des guêpes
ont fait un nid sur mon spray anti gay
c'est quel genre de concours de
circonstances à aulas aime travailler au
cinéma devoir nettoyer les conneries de
tous ces gens dégoûtant alors j'ai une
théorie sur ça pour là ils ont abusé
normand la boîte et la bouteille tu le
prends avec toi tu le jettes a sorti de
la salle mais où les pop corn qui
traînent par terre c'est normal
est ce que je dis ça parce que j'ai du
mal à manger du pop-corn dans le noir et
que j'en fais tomber sans faire exprès
par terre d'autant que oui mais je pense
qu'on en fait tous tombés sans faire
exprès par terre et ça fait pas nous des
gens horrible c'est juste basse et c'est
dur de manger du pop-corn
c'est du rouge est ok oublier tout
j'annule tout ce discours excusez moi à
chevry revenir derrière êtes-vous tendu
désormais non on a bien rigolé c'était
une bonne tranche de rire j'aime trop
cette expression c'est fou c'est
vraiment le genre de ce beau dit que
j'adore voir temps quand je passe une
sale journée
c'est horrible mais le malheur des
autres têtes à rationaliser à être moins
vénère du tiens ça te rassure que les
autres vivent des trucs encore plus
chiant c'est terrible est ce que c'est
les vacances ont envoyé cette vidéo
peut-être bien je vous souhaite de très
bonnes vacances du repos et si ça l'est
pas on vient de finir sur un truc
énervant c'est dans le thème
encore une fois j'ai bouclé la saveur
regarder a très bien en dessous
[Musique]